finn is part of the management team in
an mnc and he has come up with some
profitable investment policies for his
company and his employees
before its implementation he needs to
pitch his idea in front of the board of
directors but the board of directors
didn't approve of his idea
and that too without any explanation for
their decision
disappointed by this he started browsing
the internet looking for a solution that
could benefit everyone and where every
member gets to have their say
and that is when he came across the
concept of dao which is a decentralized
organization that is collectively owned
by its members and wherein decisions are
voted upon by themselves which runs on
blockchain technology
but to understand its concept in depth
we went to his friend sam who is a
blockchain expert
finn explained to him his situation how
he came across the dow and why he wants
to know more about it
on realizing his excitement and
curiosity sam decided to take him
through the dow and how it functions
he explained that before understanding
what dao is
let's understand a bit about what
blockchain is
blockchain is a system of storing data
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change hack or manipulate the data
it's basically a digital log of
transactions that are duplicated and
spread across the blockchain's whole
network of computers and the dow is
something that makes use of its rules
and policies for its proper functioning
he further added a dow or decentralized
economist organization is a blockchain
based organization that is collectively
owned and controlled by its members
they have built in resources that no one
can access without the group's
permission
all proposals are implemented using
voting processes to make decisions upon
its rules and policies ensuring that
everyone in the organization gets a say
this whole system majorly runs on
ethereum blockchain
sam further added that back in 2016 the
developers of the dow believe that by
putting decision-making power in the
hands of automated technology that will
eliminate the decision-making power
driven by an individual or by body it
was created to allow investors to send
money anonymously from anywhere globally
and they would issue tokens to those
owners
letting them vote on potential
initiatives or proposals
finn was fascinated and asked sam how
exactly it works and how this can be the
solution for his situation
sam explained
basically smart contracts are the
backbone of doubt
smart contracts are programs that run
when certain conditions are met and are
stored on a blockchain
let's understand this stepwise
step one is when the documentation of
the idea takes place in the similar way
in doubt a group of people write these
smart contracts to administer the
organization
once the contract goes live on the
ethereum network
changes to its rules can be proposed
only by voting the contract
automatically fails if the rules are
violated
then comes step two which is a funding
period in which pitching of ideas takes
place in front of the selected members
and investors of the organization
similarly people in the dow organization
contribute money to the dow by
purchasing tokens that signify their
membership in the organization
and when the funding period ends it
proceeds to step three
that is when the approval and
implementation process of the idea takes
place or say the dow starts to operate
people can now make proposals to the dow
on how to spend the money and how the
members can vote to approve those
proposals
this is how the first ever dow was
launched by slockett
now the question arises what led the dow
towards criticism this is due to the
infamous dow hack
back in june 2016 hackers used dow's
vulnerabilities to assault its treasury
the hackers were able to gain access to
3.6 million ethereum valued around 50
million dollars
this sparked a divisive debate among dow
investors with some demanding for the
dow to be permanently dismantled
initially vitalik buterin the founder of
ethereum advocated a soft fork of the
ethereum network
which included a piece of code that
would effectively blacklist the attacker
and prohibit them from moving the stolen
cache
but soon after the problem was detected
in its code putting it vulnerable to
assault
after great debate a second alternative
a hard fork was suggested and
subsequently implemented
the hard fork effectively reset the
ethereum network's history and move the
dal's ether to a different smart
contract allowing investors to withdraw
their assets
and as a result of the hard fork two
competing and now distinct ethereum
blockchains emerged
those who opposed the hardport which
wiped back the blockchain's history
backed the soft fork version which is
now known as ethereum classic etc
the ethereum blockchain is the
blockchain that implemented the hard
fork changing the blockchain's history
so
here is a question for you
how can you gain membership of the dow
a
by voting
b
by buying ether token
c by investing in bitcoin
d by creating smart contracts
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
the dow breach and related ethereum hard
fork shook the ethereum community and
raised serious concerns about the
developing platform
in hindsight vitalik buterin ethereum
developers and the global community made
decisions that ensured the ethereum
blockchain survival in its early days
since the dow attack ethereum has
increased in importance as a foundation
of blockchain cryptocurrency and
decentralized finance
and this occurrence i believe heralds
the start of a new age for ethereum's
public blockchain we hope you enjoyed
this video if you did a thumbs up would
be really appreciated here's your
reminder to subscribe to our channel and
click on the bell icon for more on the
latest technologies and trends thank you
for watching and stay tuned for more
from simplylearn
[Music]